I am sick of how mean the world is I'm
sick to my stunk about I think you are
as well I think everyone is can we
actually picture a world where instead
of infecting each other with anger and
upset and fear we're sparking waves of
kindness across the planet the pendulum
needs to swing and the Pendulum May
indeed be swinging one of the top
influences on YouTube is not a peddler
of Doom and Gloom he's someone who wants
to share the amazingness of life and he
does so with these kind of crazily
audacious stunts I'm talking of course
about Mr Beast and his 200 million
subscribers many of his stories are
anchored in generosity he is introducing
a whole new generation to the
possibility that generosity is actually
really cool it's a beautiful thing maybe
the new mantra for the connected age
should be something like this be brave
give what you can and then be absolutely
amazed at what happens next